c'est une rhétorique du coup d'éclats et
c'est une rhétorique de l'urgence dans
le même temps dans ce type d'action
comme ça a toujours été le cas bah la
forme est au service du fond
S
[Musique]
c'est de créer une audience dans un
espace médiatique qui est saturé et bien
ce qu'on va faire c'est essayer
d'attirer les caméras sur un événement
précis donc pour cela on utilise tous
les articles du spectacle la peinture
les gifles ou d'autres événements de ce
type et ensuite dans le texte et c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
souvent quelque chose qui tient de la
rhétorique d'urgence nous n'avons pas
d'autre choix nous aurions sans doute
préféré ne pas le faire mais on n'a pas
d'autre choix que de voir agir ainsi
on est vraiment dans la
spectacularisation du débat c'est-à-dire
que on ne va pas débattre mais on est
dans la performance dans le happning
pour attirer l'attention ce qui permet
d'attirer l'attention sur la crise
climatique c'est une action
spectaculaire ou on jette de la
nourriture sur des tableaux célèbres et
où on se colle aux dix tableaux pour
attirer l'attention et donc oui il y a
une forme de dissolution du débat dans
le spectacle qui est absolument tragique
en rhétorique quelque chose qui parfois
s'approche même du faux dilemme parce
que on essaie de coincer l'interlocuteur
en lui disant que il n'a pas d'autre
alternative que nous écoutait sinon il
est dans le rôle du coupable
[Musique]
quand on a des études scientifiques qui
tendent à dire que le réchauffement
climatique est une réalité évidemment il
y a quelque chose qui tient du domaine
de la raison dans l'esprit mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir comment
ces activistes utilisent un objet qui
est davantage axé sur le pathos pour
tenter de convaincre c'est-à-dire jouer
sur la culpabilité jouer sur le doute et
jouer sur la mauvaise conscience les
personnes qui vont écouter l'histoire
[Musique]
et si on dit oui et bien dans ce cas-là
on est catalogué comme étant une
mauvaise personne en réalité si vous
voulez c'est militants sont comme des
coucou c'est à dire qu'ils font leur
nuit dans le nid de la célébrité des
tableaux il profite comme une sorte de
passagers clandestin de la célébrité
d'un tableau pour s'y accrocher et
accrocher la notoriété qu'ils veulent
voir affublé à leur acte parce que c'est
les meules de monnaie parce que c'est la
Joconde parce que c'est les tournesols
de Van Gogh donc ils ne choisissent pas
les œuvres au hasard
[Musique]
ce qui est intéressant là du coup
d'éclat qui attire évidemment notre
attention et la majorité des
commentaires c'est que quand on
s'intéresse au discours au final on se
rend compte qu'il se réapproprie les
codes de rhétorique qui sont extrêmement
classiques c'est-à-dire qu'on voit bien
le l'utilisation des questions
rhétoriques l'utilisation des rythmes
ternaires l'utilisation des formules de
style l'utilisation aussi des arguments
admiséricordial c'est-à-dire essayer de
jouer sur la culpabilité de l'auditoire
et là on voit bien que ce n'est pas une
réinvention de la rhétorique mais ne
réappropriation de la rhétorique qui au
final a toujours été le manuel clé en
main pour convaincre et là je pense que
les activistes climatiques nous montrent
une excellente démonstration du fait que
ces outils sont en quelque sorte
totalement immortels la femme a toujours
été importante dans les discours et
notamment dans les actions l'activiste
on se souvient dactop qui non seulement
avait des actions qui étaient très
structurées sur le fond mais aussi des
actions sur la forme on est dans une
société
et
dont vous en réalité
dans l'image que constitue ces deux
jeunes femmes devant les tournesols avec
la soupe jetée puis la colle sur les
doigts et donc tout est subordonné
soumis à l'image qui emporte le tout
quel que soit les raisons de fond de la
protestation là on voit bien que on a un
type non pas de nouvelles activisme
c'est la continuation d'un activisme
notre manière aussi avec les réseaux
sociaux avec une grande différence par
rapport à top c'est dans les années 80
l'espace médiatique était assez limité
et notamment par les médias et là
désormais il faut créer une nouvelle
audience par les réseaux sociaux mais ce
qui implique un risque c'est que les
réseaux sociaux se sont aussi des
sociétés du commentaire c'est une
question qui intéresse notamment
beaucoup les scientifiques de savoir si
au fond il y a pas un danger à trop
accentuer sur le pathos mais cela on
peut répondre aussi que
convaincre uniquement par la raison ne
marche pas non plus et donc il faut un
équilibre entre la raison et l'émotion
et la deuxième question qui est aussi
liée à la première c'est malheureusement
des études qui tendent à le démontrer
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un risque de ce
qu'on appelle la réactance c'est-à-dire
l'opinion publique face à des propos qui
seraient justement à l'armistes et
catastrophique va pas réaction ne prêter
moins attention à ce type de discours un
peu sur le modèle de si votre seul
projet c'est la peur alors c'est que
vous n'avez pas de projet
malheureusement psychologie sociale ce
sont des choses qui nous ont permis de
voir d'aboutir à des résultats qui sont
assez néfastes il faut savoir il faut se
poser la question de savoir si il faut
pas aussi donner des motifs d'espoir et
parce que les sports c'est aussi un
puissant levé de conviction
[Musique]